hi i'm sandy guy
product manager for alloy db for
postgres alloy tv for postgres combines
the best of google cloud with one of the
most loved open source engines postgres
to meet the needs of top-tier relational
database workloads it's a great choice
for customers looking to modernize from
their legacy proprietary databases and
for existing postgres users looking to
scale with no application changes
in this video i'm going to tell you a
little bit more about why we built alloy
db and dive into the technology that
powers it
let's get started
[Music]
we love postgres
it's open source which means you get
full portability and a license-free cost
model but it also has rich functionality
that can compete with more expensive
proprietary systems
there's a reason why it's been adopted
by millions of users in every industry
but it has some limitations especially
if you have a more demanding production
workload
some users struggle to scale and get the
performance they need from standard
postgres
maintaining high availability takes a
lot of work managing replication and
failover without tight recovery bounce
not to mention the overhead of database
maintenance and resource management
and increasingly users want to do more
with their data
generate insights and leverage aiml to
create better experiences for their end
users
alloy db addresses these challenges head
on
with industry-leading performance and
availability it can handle any workload
you throw at it while minimizing
management overhead full postgres
compatibility means regaining the
freedom to run your applications when
and where you want and benefit from the
entire postgres ecosystem let's dive
into the technology that makes this
possible
historically a postgres database runs on
a single vm with an attached disk
it's a simple setup that works both on
premise and in the cloud but doesn't
really allow you to scale
at alloy db's core is a philosophy
around disaggregation of compute and
storage at every layer of the stack
google native technologies like bigtable
and spanner have long leveraged this
approach to scale beautifully and it has
the same benefits for alloy db
it allows us to deliver not just a
scalable system but predictable high
performance both reads and rights
so what does that look like with alloy
db we began by leveraging that same
philosophy of disaggregation separating
the database layer from the storage
we created a new intelligent storage
service
optimized for postgres that scales
separately from the database layer
this architecture reduces i o
bottlenecks and offloads work like log
processing from the primary to compute
nodes within the storage layer itself
that means faster transactional
processing
alloy db is four times faster than
standard postgres for transactional
workloads
scaling happens automatically so you
won't have to provision disk and only
pay for what you use
that means if you drop a table will
automatically adjust the storage in your
cluster
notice that even within the storage
layer itself we have disaggregation of
compute and storage as well
it allows us to make performance very
predictable by automatically adding
compute resources as needed
so you don't have to worry about
hotspots and it scales really nicely
and finally the storage layer is
regional by default the primary the
failover target and read replicas all
connect to the same fundamental regional
storage layer
that makes fast bounded recovery times
and low lag read replicas possible
in the database layer we have a fully
postgres compatible database engine with
optimizations for performance and ease
of management
smart caching improves performance we
leverage both row-based and columnar
formats to meet the needs of both
transactional workloads and operational
analytics
that means alloy db is up to a hundred
times faster than standard postgres for
analytical queries
and finally we have built-in ml-enabled
adaptive systems to make management of
postgres easier than ever from memory
management to postgres vacuum
this combination of technological
advancements gives you better
availability better performance and
easier management
all with full postgres compatibility and
customer friendly pricing to learn more
about alloy dv or create an instance go
to cloud.google.com
alloy db
and stay tuned in the next few videos
we'll dive deeper into different pieces
of the architecture and show you how
they work
[Music]
you